[Música]
este domingo 19 de junio los colombianos
elegirán entre gustavo petro y rodolfo
hernández para reemplazar a iván duque
como el presidente de colombia desde el
próximo 7 de agosto cuando asuma el
poder la primera vuelta de los comicios
presidenciales se realizará el pasado 29
de mayo afirmó que la mayoría de los
colombianos quieren un cambio de rumbo
ya que dieron sus votos a dos figuras
por fuera del espectro político
tradicional las encuestas arrojan
entonces un empate técnico entre estos
aspirantes lo que ha generado un
crispado ambiente electoral en el país
por un lado ante la posibilidad de que
la izquierda llegue por primera vez a
gobernar en colombia y por el otro la
falta de experiencia de un candidato
empresario que dice que luchará contra
la corrupción cuando enfrenta al mismo
acusaciones por este delito una campaña
marcada por ataques personales
filtraciones y la falta de debate
público entre los aspirantes a pesar de
órdenes judiciales quiero evaluar
entonces a nuestro primer invitado del
día ls bassett director del grupo de
estudios de la democracia y de la
facultad de estudios internacionales
políticos y urbanos de la universidad
del rosario en colombia
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 finalmente entonces
vamos con la última noticia sobre
colombiano habrá debate en este país en
medio de las acusaciones cruzadas entre
los candidatos qué opinión le merece que
no se haga un posible cara cara previo a
esta segunda vuelta de las elecciones
efectivamente no va a haber debate en
esta segunda vuelta y es algo que ha
permitido de cierto modo que la compañía
se haya vuelto muy sucia digamos en esta
en esta segunda vuelta ha sido una
compañía muy a punto de acusaciones
recíprocas en los medios de comunicación
y de hecho con participación de los
medios de comunicación y el hecho de no
tener debate seguramente pues ha ayudado
a ésta a esta degradación de la compañía
en esta en esta segunda vuelta vamos a
seguir ampliando el tema un poquito más
adelante de nuestra conversación pero le
quiero preguntar en este momento qué va
a pasar con los votos es decir los
candidatos llegan entonces a esta
segunda vuelta del domingo con un empate
técnico muchos indecisos otros también
van a optar por un voto en blanco porque
ninguno de los candidatos
le convenció de mente para botarlo esta
población
digamos que tan necesario que tan
importante va a ser para definir al
ganador de estos comicios
efectivamente son unas elecciones de
mucha incertidumbre entonces no
solamente por el empate técnico como lo
dijo sino además por el nivel muy alto
de indecisos en esta segunda vuelta lo
que lo que muestra que ambas compañías
finalmente generan mucha resistencia y
que hay una franja muy grande de lectura
es que tiene muchas dificultades a
resolverse por uno o por otro con una
lógica de mal menor' digamos y eso pues
hace que puede pasar cualquier cosa
realmente el escenario es muy muy
previsible y pues es muy difícil prever
quién de los dos podría hacer presidente
este domingo hay dos grandes polémicas
en esta campaña que también se han
salido a la luz han salido a la luz y se
han presentado en los últimos días estos
llamados o petro vídeos filtraciones de
una conversación dentro de la campaña
del candidato de la izquierda gustavo
petro que tan dicientes son estos vídeos
y que tanto le pudieran afectar
de la decisión de los votantes
pues es un ejemplo digamos de los
escandalosos digamos que fue estas
compañías de segunda vuelta no a punto
de pequeños escándalos y con una
participación muy clara de los medios
como lo decía porque pues ahí hay
algunos medios que se dedicaron a
publicar este y estos vídeos que
finalmente pues había polémico es
incluso incluso sobre el contenido lo
que muestran de escandaloso esos vídeos
digamos es que hay discusiones en la
compañía de gustavo petro que muestran
que su equipo de jóvenes particularmente
la campaña digital se han dedicado a una
compañía negativa a veces apunta de a de
calumnias de críticas al adversarios lo
que pues es una cosa que no sorprenderá
a los profesionales pero pues que se ve
muy mal digamos
pero pero a veces digamos que estos
vídeos han sido presentados como un gran
escándalo cuando finalmente el contenido
pues es algo que sabemos que sucede en
todas las compañías de cierto modo
entonces está el hecho finalmente de que
el debate la discusión pública se haya
volcado sobre estas estas filtraciones
más que sobre propuestas más que sobre
ideas podríamos hablar también del papel
de los medios en las críticas a la otra
acompaña a la de rodolfo hernández
alrededor de polémicas alrededor de su
hija que fue secuestrada en fin cosas
realmente desde compañía negra que que
no aportaron mucho a la discusión
pública agravante público y que
terminaron ensuciando profundamente esta
campaña precisamente ya no hablemos del
otro candidato de rodolfo hernández el
candidato anti corrupción precisamente
acusado de corrupción que tan además
hablé hablando de propuestas que tan
realistas pueden ser las propuestas y
alcanzables las errores fernández
rodolfo hernández 9 es una compañía y
propuesta realmente este discurso
anticorrupción ha sido el centro de su
campaña un discurso dirigido focalizado
en contra de la clase política que es
muy popular pero con un contenido que a
veces tiene muchos vacíos no y que ha
tratado de colmar un poco al último
momento en la compañía de segunda vuelta
sin siempre convencer mucho entonces hay
mucha incertidumbre sobre cómo sería un
gobierno de rodolfo hernández no
solamente a nivel de propuestas y que
sería cuáles serían sus políticas sino
además de cómo gobernaría porque este
discurso antipolítico de crítica
generalizada a la clase política plantea
el problema de bueno como con con qué
tipo de mayoría en el congreso podría
gobernar es muy difícil realmente llegar
a gobernar con un discurso que pretende
criticar a todo el mundo y decir que
todo el sistema está está está corrupto
y eso plantea muchos interrogantes sobre
sobre qué pasaría digamos con un
gobierno de rotor fernández claro ya ni
también le quiero plantar si hay una
posibilidad de que alguno de los
candidatos no reconozca los resultados
que se van a producir luego de estas
elecciones del domingo 19 de junio
representaría esto un riesgo para el
país un riesgo para la democracia
efectivamente eso también es objeto de
polémico pues en el caso de rodolfo
hernández ha dicho de antemano que
reconocería el resultado pero gustavo
petro ha sido mucho más ambiguo gustavo
petro se apoya sobre antecedentes
complicados de las elecciones de marzo
en que el conteo rápido de la
registraduría arrojó resultados que
finalmente fueron corregidos después en
el escrutinio con un millón de votos más
para gustavo petro eso demuestra que el
sistema funciona de cierto modo pero
pues dejar un antecedente complicado y
la compañía de gustavo petro ha
denunciado fraude que les querían sacar
esos votos en fin y eso pues
efectivamente plantea uno a uno desde
consonante sedante complicado para la
selección presidenciales sobre todo si
hay un margen muy estrecho con muchas
dudas finalmente desde que la compañía
de gustavo petro acepte una derrota
estrecha y eso pues es algo que genera
también muchos temores no para lo que
puede pasar domingo